do you think women should be bailed out
um yeah i think if what
is it
so out of out of the things we talked
about today
what would you say women should and
shouldn't be bailed out for
so are you talking about um
which bridge aspects so we talked about
a lot of we talked about child support
we talked about um we talked about
voting and the draft we talked about
abortion
so basically of all the things that like
women are bailed out for
i think no fault divorce god i think one
should be
um
the child support
based on this one aspect
is at the time the child is born the man
signs a piece of paper to consent to
that child
so that way it's fair in the sense of
if it does break down and say he's the
one to initiate the
initiate the divorce
she's not out of pocket because
by she's had to sacrifice her career and
by no way that's not her fault the man
has left and left her
with
having to sacrifice her career and
essentially no money then i think under
those conditions and yeah she should be
provided support
what about you guys
um yes i agree what you said as well
under those circumstances
um
with regards to um
abortion
i feel like there are many
contraceptions and that you can take
there's more than after pill there's
other all these other pills
um and there's ways to protect yourself
so i do feel like women should
be accountable for for that as well
especially if um
in this day and age
um
so yeah i think
some things and some things not mm-hmm
yeah what was the original thing oh so
i'm asking what do you think women
should be bailed out for and what do you
think they should not be bailed out for
okay yeah i think women should be
bailed out for things that are going to
have an impact maybe on their mental
health or
is gonna have like a on their mental
health just like in general yeah just
like their men like even like their well
their general well-being right i think
but i think but i believe
i believe everyone obviously should have
access because i'm all about everyone i
love everyone
peace people
yeah but you know everyone should have
access to resources that can support
them in
improving
so
so you think if i choose not to work as
a woman and i rely on like the men's
handouts you think i should be bailed
out for that decision because working
makes me have mental health issues
that's the interest i think obvi that's
actually a really interesting question
you know because you know maybe i'm just
not made to work
i shouldn't well i think you know but
it's but there there is that case right
where women there's women out there that
work and
it affects their mental health right
they can't they can't cop they can't
cope with work or they can't cope with a
lot of things in life okay so your
answer would be yes we should bail them
out i think we should support people who
need support okay so if i chose not to
work because it affected my mental
health i should be bailed out for that
decision by men
yeah
don't you think that's a bit entitled
i think yeah it is entitled when i'm
entitled yeah but but you've got very i
know you're
obviously coming to saying okay well
women should be bailed up i remember
obviously i'm saying that i think that
anyone in
who who who
who is struggling with life
um struggling with their well-being
struggling with their health should be
given that support including men and
it's and it's a shame as well that was
we're talking that it's like
you've even like even the men here are
confirming that those services don't
exist for them you know
um
well but the problem is because you can
only have so many handout programs so
it's like my dad would always explain
you like put two dollars into something
you you take one dollar out
like like even okay i make money in this
business off of like super chats on the
show sometimes i lose money
on these shows right but i make money in
other areas to make up for it so like
when you're talking about like free
government handouts you can only have so
many people on government dependency
and so like you saw that during the
pandemic there's a lot of people that
were paid not to work
and so you can't pay everyone not to
work no you can't because then that
would just have a right right
so how how would you like navigate that
because if you're paying people not to
work more people aren't going to work
yeah yeah
no i i totally get that and i think
you know by supporting people
and helping them so they can get into a
mentality where they can work that would
obviously be but what about the people
that just don't want to
because like i i don't have that now
though don't we right we do and that's
what i'm saying like most of the uh
all the hard working like people i know
like why do they have to pay for the
people that just choose to do nothing
because they're mentally unstable
i think that's just because they're
mentally i say because we want every
because i think as a society we want
people to have a contribution
right so they should make one and get a
job wouldn't you agree
like shouldn't they shouldn't they make
a contribution by getting a job i think
they i think that we should
be putting people we should be
supporting people so that they can get a
job right but i'm saying like the people
that don't want to work because it
affects their mental health
it also depends on the type of mental
health you know yeah i feel like if you
are someone that is having panic attacks
anxiety um
you know
there are jobs that wait that you can
tell they can support you through your
your job but then again
what it depends on what type of jobs
that they can go for
if as you said about someone i just say
you know i don't feel like working i'm
just i'm gonna find somebody to look
after me i think
usually those types of women sometimes
they go for a certain guy
or they position themselves
i would say sometimes
especially on instagram they will
position themselves where they're going
to find
that type of person that can look after
them or just tag along with them and
just get treated
but i'm asking how you would navigate
that
like how would you know who just doesn't
want to work because they don't feel
like it
i think you would know by just knowing
what what meant what is the actual
mental health that they've got right but
i'm saying like at a policy perspective
anyone can say
i have mental health issues let me not
work like i mean in the pandemic i saw
it firsthand in the u.s like they gave
out so much free [ __ ] that like i know
people that quit their jobs
today in that that that life i think the
pan yeah i definitely think the pandemic
did people got used to being at home
you know i mean especially
it was they were paying more than some
of their jobs like to like they're
literally getting paid to like do
nothing
yeah and then that's also now show
people oh i can sit down and not do
nothing and get money
it's it's it's i don't know how you can
distinguish it though it is
it yeah
yeah so that's i was asking if you knew
how you would distinguish that
like from a policy perspective it's okay
if you don't know no i don't yeah like i
think yeah obviously that would that
would need to be worked out like i don't
think it's possible if i'm being real i
just don't think it's possible to
distinguish
essentially putting it out there because
you know it's a problem and there's a
need for it however you're looking at
people essentially to just trust people
to do it and people will manipulate the
system and i think that's the problem
with the left they don't actually look
on the knock-on effect and anything to
do with uh economy there's an
opportunity cost when you do something
it's going to affect someone in a in
another way so when you look at say
martin luther king the fact that he
marched for everyone to have the ability
to have a liberty to get a job that
meant more white people didn't get jobs
because more black people were working
so the same way a lot of people were
complaining about
they wanted the furlough scheme to put
money in their pockets but now we have
this
uh cost of living crisis where inflation
is sky high globally and now people are
suffering below the poverty line if we
just had not done the furlough situation
we would not be in the situation we're
in now but everyone was calling for at
the time and that's why there's no
consequential thinking when it comes to
leftism they think of we live in this
airy fairy land unfortunately the world
is hard so if we pick one policy it's
gonna it's gonna hurt some people that's
what it is and the question is what
percentage of your paycheck would you be
willing to give up for that policy